hi my name is ileane Chu and I'm a
software developer in warfarin research
welcome to the talk about modeling multi
basics with PDEs and in this talk I will
introduce what PDE model is and I will
show you several application models and
demonstrate the workflow to do PDE
modeling in the Wolfram language
hi hello everyone welcome my name is
ileane Chu and I'm a software developer
here in the Wolfram research and welcome
to the talk about modeling multiphysics
with PDEs for this talk I will start
with a brief introduction the PDE models
and then I will spend most of the time
on the real-life examples showing you
the workflow to do PDE modeling in the
Wolfram language so PD e stands for
partial differential equations and PDE
models are set of equations that
describe the physics in life for example
we can use wave equation to describe the
sum propagation in here and we can use
heat equation to take to describe the
heat transfer in a thermodynamic system
and even more we can couple different
PDE s together to simulate the
interaction between different physics
and once we construct these PDE models
we can solve it numerically in the
wulfing language and this is done using
our powerful function called undissolved
and here we'll use finite element method
as our numerical method so currently we
are writing tutorials about PD modeling
in different physical fields we have
background Theory tutorials complete in
acoustic field and heat transfer field
and we also have many application
examples in different physical fields
and all these tutorials are wrapped in
the PDE models overview page so you can
go to help and click on documentation
Center let me make this a little bit
larger okay so you you can search for
PDE model over view
and click on it and you can see all the
tutorials we have for PT modeling for
example if you want to build a heat
transfer model then you can go to the
heat transfer tutorial and we have the
background theory about heat transfer PD
model and how you can construct it in
the Wolfram language and also we have
the examples for example I click on
acoustics application models and I go to
acoustic muffler and here we are
modeling three different types of
acoustic muffler and we can simulate and
compare their performance so let me go
directly to the end so something like
this and even more if we have an audio
input I guess it is not playing okay
okay so yeah this song is not working
but yeah let's say you have an input
audio then you can even simulate the
song output from this muffler okay so
let's go back to our slide so in the
following I will walk you through an
example and to do pde modeling in
warfarin language there are three major
steps the first step is to set up our PD
model and then we will solve it
numerically in using and dissolve and
then once we got the result we can do
some post-processing like animation and
analysis so okay let's start with this
example here I have a tungsten wire at
both end I apply a voltage and this will
introduce electric current flow within
the wire and due to this current flow
like part of the current flow will
convert into the thermal energy and hits
up the wire so to model this I will
first construct a electrostatics model
to simulate the electric field V and
then based on this electric field I can
construct another heat transfer model to
simulate the temperature evolution
within the wire so let's get started so
let's set up our electrostatics model so
first I define their simulation domain
and next I specify the governing PDE and
this is done in Mathematica using the
symbolic representation and and then I
need to specify the boundary condition
so at both end which mark Ingrid and
yellow I apply voltage so I used
original condition to specify the
electric potential
the left end and the right end and now
our model is set up and ready to be sold
the solving process is very simple we
just send our PD models into undissolved
here is the PDE we just specify and the
boundary condition we set up and here we
are solving for electric field V over
the 3d domain the return will be an
interpolating function so let's take a
look at our result so here first we can
visualize the electric potential field
over the wire at the left end it is held
at point to vote and the right end it is
fixed at 0 X what we expected okay so
based on the electric field V found we
saw four we can calculate the electric
heat generation and this heat generation
is in proportional to the square of the
electric gradient and this is done in
Wolfram language using this line which
is very simple and we can see the heat
generated the most at the inner edge of
the wire oh ok so it is hided here it is
not a it is a lot of code but it it is
not complicated because I like I use the
I have to set up the legend bar and the
kind of thing yeah but yes it's in cue
and with this cue we can even calculate
the total heat generation over the
entire domain and this is bound by
integrating over the domain and in
Wolfram language we have a function
called an integrate and we find the
total heat generation it's about there
what so as you see to do this kind of
post processing in the Wolfram language
it is very easy because Wolfram language
is an integrated software and we have
many powerful function for numerical
computing so this is one man advantage
to do pd modeling in our framework so
now for now we have solved for the
electric field and the electric heat
generation let's build a heat transfer
model to simulate the temperature
distribution over the wire so to do so
recall that we have the heat generation
Q that we just compute and using this Q
we can we build the heat transfer PD
model and here I make use of PD modeling
function and these functions are
provided in our tutorial so if we go to
the PD models overview page and here we
are modeling heat transfer so we go to
heat transfer and we go to heat transfer
model setup then you can find the PD
modeling function here and we will teach
you how to use it and what arguments we
need so next we have to set up the
initial condition and the boundary
condition so for the initial condition
we assume the wire temperature is equals
to ambient temperature at the beginning
of the heating process and for the
boundary condition at both end the wire
temperature is held at 300 Kelvin which
is equal to ambient temperature so we we
use the original condition to model this
and on the site boundary which is
marking orange the heat is dissipating
due to the thermal radiation and thermal
convection so this I model this using
Newman value
and if you want to find this formula you
don't have to look it up by yourself the
only thing you do is go to the our
tutorial and here I got a section
entitled boundary conditions in heat
transfer and I list a lot of boundary
conditions that is ready for your use
so now let's so for our heat transfer
model as usual I just send my PD model
into and dissolve and I saw for the wire
temperature for the first 300 seconds so
let's take a look at the result
I can buta the animation to to visualize
the temperature illusion and also I can
calculate the heat dissipation due to
the thermal radiation convection and
conduction so this is done by boundary
integration so I again use an integrate
and I found the radiation key loss is
about seven point five two what I can do
I can compute the helos VR convection
and conduction in the similar way so for
now we have complete a sequential PDE
model at first we solve for the electric
Butte and electrostatics model to
simulate the electric field V and based
on this field electric field V we build
another heat transfer model to simulate
the temperature field we can solve this
in sequence because the electric field
doesn't depends on the temperature but
imagine what if we are modeling two
different physics they will interact
with each other then in that case we can
now solve the model in sequence so in
this case we will say we have an fully
cop whole PD model
and to build and solve for a fully Kappa
PD model in warfarin language the
workflow is very much the same the only
difference is that we have to construct
our PD es construct all of our pretties
at the same at the first step group it
together to form a couple PD systems and
then we will solve these couple PD
systems at the same time and then we can
do some post-processing so let's take a
look at this result this example so here
I'm modeling a heat exchanger the co
flow is coming in from the bottom flow
over several heating tubes and then exit
the domain from top I'm interested in
the temperature field and the flow field
within the system so I have to build a
heat transfer model and fluid dynamics
model so note that the temperature
depends on the flow field and the flow
field also depends on the temperature
which make it a volley couple PD model
so let's set up our model so as usual we
define our simulation domain and then we
construct the heat heat transfer PD
model and the flu dynamics model and
again I use the PDE modeling function
here and next I have to set up the
boundary condition for example I have to
specify the flow velocity at the flow
Inlet and I can so I can model other
boundary conditions in the similar
manner and then I group all the boundary
conditions together for the later use
and now let's so for our PD model so to
solve for these couple PD models we have
to group all the PDS together
to form a couple PD system and then we
just send it into undissolved so our
powerful undies of function can solve
for these can handle these nonlinear and
couple equations so let's take a look at
the result so we can visualize the
temperature distribution using contour
plots and we can expect the flow
velocity using the arrow plot and two we
can also calculate the mean temperature
at the outlet to see the performance of
this heat exchanger so this is done
using the boundary integration and again
we use an integrate so you can see the
temperature has been raised by three
hundred Kelvin to three hundred point
three Kelvin yeah so today we have we
see a sequential PD model and we build
this sequential PD model to simulate and
the electric heating of the wire and
next we construct the Foley couple PD
models to simulate the interaction
between flow field and the temperature
field and you can find more example like
this in our tutorial so let's go yeah
here I have the maybe I should make this
larger yeah here I have examples in
acoustics and I have examples in fluid
dynamics and I have XML in heat transfer
and even more I have examples for multi
physics which models the interaction
between different physical fields so
yeah this is what I have today thank you
very much and if you you can download
this light using this QR code and you
can find all the tutorials in our in the
documentation Center in the PDE models
overview page some of the tutorials are
already available and some of them will
be ready in 12.1 version thank you very
much thank you